Drake has a lot of people talking but
his new tattoo that he started showing
off over the past few weeks so Drake
recently passed the Beatles and the
Billboard record books for the amount of
songs he's had in the top 10 so he just
passed them with 35 so Drake got a new
tattoo yeah now first take a look at the
Beatles Abbey Road album cover iconic
picture of course that photo actually
just celebrated its 50th anniversary on
Thursday now take a look at a recent pic
of Drake there he is with PK Subin but
take a look at the tattoo one drinks
forearm we've got a closer picture of it
and so there's the fat for walking and
Drake in front of them stopping them you
know a that's a lot of people think this
is a poor taste what do you think I
think I don't know man I it's not a
tattooed personally that I would get but
I do I wouldn't get tattoos of myself on
myself right but that's the one thing to
do like that talk to yourself on
yourself but if I mean he is the person
that did it
it is it's symbolic of a thing that he
did I could get it I maybe I think
people wouldn't be as upset if it was
like a painting in his house or
something right but just because it's
had to on him people are more upset is
because like opposite Drake is hugely
successful yeah he's probably the
biggest star right now yeah but I mean
it's such a different world in terms of
streaming and stuff like that you can
like because you used to be how do you
measure it right because you used to be
no you know bands artists only release
one song you know it was all based on
sales you can't stream anything yeah so
having to go out and buy that song yeah
so it's a very different world but cuz
streaming like some of these artists
these days have like like Nicki Minaj
passed the wreath to Franklin is like I
don't think anyone would argue that
Nicki ah she's a bigger artist there's a
well there's a lot there's like people
are consuming more in general right
there are a lot but then on the flip
side of that there are a lot more
artists that you could be surpassing so
if you're the one person that surpassed
the people that were unsurpassable I
mean it's a landmark I know it's a huge
I just feel like the tattoo that on
yourself and like the Beatles are
whatever top five artists of all time
yeah like top two artists of all yeah so
like I don't know it just seems like a
little not exactly a trend right yeah
like I love like I find Drake like
there's something's all about Drake
there's some things I really don't like
about Rick and this is one thing I just
fine it's a little bit now much is
erasers don't mess with the Beatles
is he really stopping them or is he
walking in front of them going hey guys
come on come looks like come follow me
we're gonna go get some other way way to
say like follow me but yeah yeah so it
could be either he's putting his hand to
stop them or saying you're following me
that's behind me I just fit us all
getting a much closer look at that and
people kind of calming down a little bit
all those like the icons that paved your
way Byron says it's weird see he's
always says people remember the Beatles
but no one will remember Drake for 50
years I I'm gonna have to disagree with
that I think that I think that there are
people that are making music now that
are going to be the icons of 20 30 40 50
years in the future I think he's
probably one of them yeah Andrew says it
would be better with those that paved
the way it's a little disrespectful or
authority me I don't get what you're
saying maybe tattoo beetles I don't get
very single [ __ ] I can put that
together into a sentence you agree or
disagree I thought of you
but thanks for commenting okay